it's gonna mess with my hair man you're
gonna leave your glass always sorry he's
gonna say no where did Matt go I don't
know I mean he needs to see like an
intellectually you look like a Tekken
character a customized Tekken Eric there
I'm having an exceptionally good time
with it because of the fact that it's
not a mechanic that's required in
previous problems not from soft games so
like to be challenged to do that it's
something that's so fulfilling for me
because I'm terrible like timing like
parries and counters and stuff but this
games like the it's like the lifeblood
of combat it's all about like looking at
an attack ping like actual attention and
then just timing like guard guard guard
I really liked that because of the fact
that it you know like I finally feel
like I understand it like it's almost
kind of transferred to other like games
that are played nowadays - yeah like I I
would love to go back and play more like
fighting games just yeah there's a
moment in the with one of these bosses
where I had like my like die go like
even moments where I'm just like Peri
Peri Peri Peri Peri Peri just blow and
then just finish them off and you're
like I feel so powerful right now every
enemy is just a long
[Music]
and it's it's weird because like
compared to Dark Souls or other thumb
games where I think they give you more
options initially for like how to play
it like you said I'm gonna play a row
I'm gonna play like a shield guy like
this game kind of like demands that you
play it more on its terms and it's like
you have to learn how to parry you have
to learn how to playing a character
that's depending on the movie yeah
you're playing a very specific character
and I was originally worried that was
going to be more limiting or like I
wasn't gonna like it as much but I I'm
really enjoying that it's forcing me to
like learn a make systems in a way that
I feel like Dark Souls kind of let me
get away sometimes with like not having
to learn that stuff right it makes the
whole experience that much more focused
and I think that's the thing that's more
that's very refreshing about the game is
that it's very direct compared to like
something like Dark Souls like the
storytelling is way more direct the fact
that you're playing is a character has
these very specific abilities that you
have to master is very direct about the
game like it's a lot more tailored in
that regard not that to say that any of
the other games from some are not
tailored either in any regard but just
the fact that like this is the way that
we want you to play the game yes is the
story that we're trying to tell is
something that comes across more in this
that's just so different it's so much
more compelling for me I mean I don't
know I mean I granted I've only played
like a lot of blood-borne that's kind of
my experience with these from Sophos
games but that grow as a result this
just comes across so refreshing isn't it
because of that yeah I was gonna say I
really liked that not it was we talk a
lot about all are a lot about how you
have to parry to fight the bosses and I
like how the idea of playing that
character who is more of a like a
stealth action sneaky type of guy even
goes out when the one you're dealing
with regular enemies where I feel like
I'm getting rewarded much better for it
going on sneaking around and not being
seen and taking everyone out
about getting caught which is a thing
that you don't do in almost any Souls
game almost like you get like a backstab
off on someone but then all of a sudden
everyone turns and looks at you here I
can I can make my way through an entire
group of enemies without being seen and
there a lot of abilities to help me with
that yeah just like the mobility in your
options like that is where the game does
if you like present more options yeah
you have like a more specific set of
tools but there's like more ways to use
those tools I feel like so this is a
game that I'm on my second playthrough
and I've been like not quite
speedrunning it but kind of like going
through it really quickly and and
figuring out like there are always like
four to five different paths to like one
location of like you know you can go
like grapple up and like run on the
rooftops and you can go like straight
forward you can go like shimmy on the
ledge to the left and there's all this
variation and how you approach yes to
combat area you know because you can
just like run in and have a sword fight
or you could be like I'm gonna try to
save me around good try stopping
everybody I'm gonna take out that big
guy first it feels like they give you a
space and like you like really explore
that like combat space in a way that
like Dark Souls it was a little more
Street yeah or you like they have to go
here and this guy's gonna jump out from
behind and then I'm gonna like you know
kill him and then I'm gonna kind of keep
forward yeah yeah like you're just
you're more mobile and I think that that
is where the games like variety comes
from and it makes like playing in a
second time really satisfying because
I'm like I'm gonna take this alternate
path and I'm gonna go this way and I'm
gonna like stealth kill that guy or this
time I'm gonna try and fight him and I
find that like really rewarding about
the game yeah just to have options with
something that has such a high
difficulty and such like high sort of
sort of ceiling to learn from or try to
learn and understand its mechanics it's
great that you have just several ways
you can go about a situation at all
times yeah you know like sure I want to
practice combat but then like no I want
to stealth it this time I want to think
about how I can maybe just maybe try to
explore the environment a bit maybe take
a bit more advantage of the different
paths that are presents to you because
there's a lot more feels like there's a
lot of different paths to take it like
the levels are are designed a more
openly
yeah not just like a linear path you
take like oh I gotta kill this out of
you in this enemy uh you know like
you're still killing enemies but you
look like okay
approach from up here and then like
stealth kill them down here and then
like look to that dude you won't notice
me and then just go from there it's it's
nice to have options after a while
because especially when you're you know
in like a dark skull Dark Souls game or
just beating your head against the wall
trying to master being able to like get
through a particular section right yeah
that's something that this game I think
does really well and the other Dark
Souls in like blood-borne did that
really well where I had multiple areas
like the optional area so you can
completely ignore it this game I think
only one area is I actually option all
the rest of you have to do but there is
a point in the game where it kind of
opens up and it lets you go in all these
different directions like and you can
kind of pick the order you want and I
did notice that actually changes the way
the game works like there are there is
this to later game areas where if you go
any fight this boss and then if you go
do the other area there will be a
optional second boss that shows up
specifically because you killed that
boss and you have to fight that boss to
progress it I was like but I never did
that I went and did the other area first
and then I went back and killed that
first boss so that other boss showed up
as an optional boss later like I could
go back and fight him as I wanted to but
I have to beat him the way that other
people like it basically changed whether
that boss was optional or not depending
on which order you did things in yeah
and then and personally if you like
there would be one area that added these
like extra enemies because I did this
one thing first so like kind of poking
out like where the game how the game
changes depending on what you do in like
what choices you make first and like
what paths you go down like it
eventually does funnel into this you
know like you kind of have to do
everything but the decisions you make
along the way and where you go you don't
even realize they are decisions but it
does change the way the game works and I
think that is maybe my favorite part
about the game and like blood-borne two
that a little bit yeah with some areas
like there's this one area in
blood-borne where you would depending
whether you beat a boss first they would
change that area tonight and some of the
enemies would be harder but this takes
it to like a whole other level that I
think is like really really cool
see I like how it's like you're saying
insight into how the narrative can
actually play out but I also like when
we all came back after like playing for
a little bit we'd all have different
stories like oh I went off this way and
I went and I saw this guy but then like
you went off and saw someone else
completely different and it's not just
the narrative in the game that's
different but also people who are
playing its kind of experience because
it opens up like different paths and you
can take
they'll eventually lead to the same
thing which is kind of cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's like any other from games like
where we're this stack for you for me
yeah
I think it might be one of my favorites
because it's got that I've got the
stealth action bias okay so like I like
the fact that I can sneak around and
there's a lot more kind of tactical
thinking I can apply to it besides just
I'm gonna dress this enemy fight it and
then move on to the next one which I
enjoy a lot and I wouldn't knock in any
way but I love the fact that I can
stealth around and feel really cool just
taking dudes out without their friends I
enjoy I like it a lot it's definitely up
there for me yeah I probably put it my
favorite Souls game was born gay my
guess is blood-borne and a lot of that
has to do with like the aesthetic of
that game is just like I absolutely love
that sort of like Gothic cathedral or I
think this games probably got my
favorite combat have any for a software
game it feels so refined and like how it
wants you to play it like what you have
to do in that parry system like it just
it feels so good to play it's like I
don't wanna say their comments bad or
it's just like it's a little so more
like sloppy a little more imprecise and
I think it actually like works for those
games very well but there's like a
precision to like the rhythm of like the
whites in this game there's basic
cadence - yeah it's really really good
so it's hard to say whether it was like
beeps blood-borne it's like you love
those stuffs so much but something about
like the actual combat of playing this
game I think it's maybe my new favorite
yeah I agree - man like Sakura like
granted you know a beat blood-borne
I've you know gotten a decent chunk into
Dark Souls but like Sakura is something
I think I think I have my own biases in
that same way - like I like really or
like stealth action stuff I love like
ninjas like samurai films Kurosawa stuff
and I just love all the different
aspects of place how this game function
is what it takes with like you know
putting you in sort of like you know
like a fictionalized version of like you
know like each of Japan and stuff which
is like that's cool and interesting in a
no itself it's refreshing like seeing
from Sophos like take on history that's
still kind of grounded within something
but then just the combat like I just
keep wanting to reiterate just how
fantastic how like the amount of like
reward I feel after like reading a
really hard boss in SEC euro is
tremendous like more so than anything I
feel like I've ever felt in blood-borne
in a globalised fantastic game with its
boss fights but just like how everything
in SEC Euro I think in its combat feels
like just like an uphill battle because
you're just trying to like whittle away
this trying to get this guy's posture up
there and sometimes it starts going down
and you feel anything all of your
progress and it just feels hopeless
bleak you feel almost despair because
you're like I how can I do this how can
i penetrate this how can I like beat
this boss but once you get it you just
start doing things perfectly and you
start like surrendering any of that
urgency that you had you know getting
your first initial a couple tries when
you're just trying to understand how
calm up works and you're just like doing
things flawlessly it perfectly worked
like if enemy's actions like his attacks
just seems slow like you're just like
wait there's just nothing nothing like
it wasn't as you can see the matrix I'm
walking the path now back to shinobi but
yeah dude it's just so like exhilarating
I freaking love it and for that reason
alone I think Zack here was just like
stacks up just so high for me on you
know from softs like sort of repertoire
of caves
[Music]